allez on se dépêche on a déjà identifié
et c'est plutôt un gros poisson une
balle à pointe creuse un deuxième du
jour je pense que ça va vous intéresser
salut les gars comment ça va mon fils
papa vous en êtes où j'en suis con amène
pas de civils sur une scène de crime on
arrête on peut pas dire que ce soit une
civile comme les autres regardent all à
1 pour jour je suis toni car vous aussi
vous êtes le flepia j'ai fait sept ans
de prison et c'est un flic aux méthodes
contestables mais j'avoue qu'on aime
bien rire de 30 d'accor
on voit qu'ils vivent pas avec nous dj
dit que vous êtes les meilleurs flics de
la ville c'est moi qui lui tout a pris 1
c'est normal sauf la différence entre le
bien et le mal
sachez-le et après tout ça si on
respecte pas les règles tous ses
attraits tu te demandes pourquoi plus
personne et invite au soir et je vous ai
observés pendant la cérémonie
comment vous vous chalutier vous
provoquez il est entre vos profonde
affection et mme rell dans son
stationnement
vous exagérez le tromper un fléau du
télésiège est l un des clients a été
assassiné le docteur comme loup vient
d'envoyer une autopsie qui je vois rien
de louche lui ryan c'est mieux il ya
quelque chose que tout bon film devrait
toujours se rappeler c'est quoi
et le 18 heures je te le dirai demain
les séminaires de fixer le pied éthique
dans le monde de la police actuel je
m'inscris à une conférence ça a été
difficile d'entrer dans le panel j'ai dû
graisser quelques battements payé un
pot-de-vin pour m'envoyer un panel sur
l'éthique ça m'a coûté 50 balles tu
seras pourrais moi je serais contre
ce qui se passe quand on respecte les
règles à la lettre excuse moi de quoi il
ya un souci c'est mon père
bon oui
tu peux être à nouveau mon fils je
voulais pas te le dire avant mais tout à
l'heure je tavernier et j'ai hâte de le
dire haut comme pas toi alors